hey youtubers it's Charlie so recently
they dropped a whole bunch of new
behind-the-scenes stuff for Star Wars
The Force awakens and JJ Abrams along
with a bunch of the cast we're talking
about the movie there were some
hilarious quotes so I'm gonna play this
behind-the-scenes featurette then I'm
gonna talk about some of the funniest
things that they said Sowell's it's an
incredible story of people finding their
place in a world these characters their
lives though they're in a galaxy far far
away it's a journey that people can
relate to I feel honored that I've been
allowed to continue the journey what
happens to these characters that we know
and love it's the world I want to get
back to immediately Star Wars magic it
does take your breath away
and that is something that George Lucas
started or definitely carrying that one
I've been a Star Wars fan as an adult
and a child mean this is crazy
just look around oh my gosh oh my gosh
every single person who's come to the
project has been a huge Star Wars fan
I'm literally shaking like this is
insane it's this cross-generational
group of people who are bringing all of
those sensibilities to the making of
this movie this part of my Star Wars
journey is quite different now because
now I feel part of the family we're
going back to these stories that people
feel intensely about
really the whole point of this clip is
just showing how the new actors are
experiencing like their deep dive into
the Star Wars universe Harrison Ford
Carrie Fisher Mark Hamill they've been
living it for so long but these actors
never saw the original trilogy in
theaters so it's almost brand new for
them stepping into this world and just
to be clear yeah a lot of people saw the
prequels in the theaters because those
came out much more recently but JJ
Abrams said that most of the inspiration
for Episode seven came from the original
trilogy so when the new actors are
experiencing things for the first time
they're really experiencing the world of
the original trilogy which is actually a
nice segue to funny things overheard
during Star Wars press conferences so
Lawrence Kasdan writer the movie along
with JJ Abrams has written a whole bunch
of Star Wars
he said the funniest quote in the world
he said I've written for Star Wars
movies and I do not know what the Canon
is the big controversy in the fandom was
that they kind of threw the expanded
universe out so it's not canon anymore
if you don't know what Canon means Canon
is just the stuff that the author's
acknowledge as actually happening inside
the universe of the story so when we say
something is not canon anymore like
Grand Admiral Thrawn there might have
been a bunch of books about him that
were amazing and they were if you
haven't read em you totally should in
the new trilogy those characters
essentially don't exist anymore so Grand
Admiral Thrawn for all intents and
purposes does not exist that's just one
example but I think that it's hilarious
that Lawrence Kasdan who's written for
Star Wars movies probably one of the
most important people in the world of
Star Wars has absolutely no idea what
the Canon is that's just the funny
takeaway just add a little more context
to what he was talking about he was
mostly talking about like little kids
experiencing the trilogy like they don't
care what the backstory is they just
love saying the x-wings flying around on
screen they love seeing lightsaber
fights big spectacles without actually
knowing what the literal story is like
they might not understand what the
nature of the forces or the particular
x' but they know that it's really
special so he's really just saying that
for a large portion of the audience
Canon doesn't mean anything
but it is hilarious to see that in a
headline Star Wars boss has absolutely
no idea what the Canon is more funny
quotes moving on to your favorite
foul-mouthed old mistress of the Star
Wars universe Carrie Fisher she gives
the funniest interviews just because she
has the dirtiest sense of humor everyone
remember the cinnamon roll hairdo she
was calling her new hairdo in episode 7
the
baboon's ass so I just love the idea
that she said she was walking around
through this entire film with the
baboon's ass on her head Lupita was
asked a little bit about her character's
relationship with Yoda
because she's a thousand years old he
was about 900 years old she joked that
he was my first love I would love to see
that movie from Disney you know it's
kinda like winking at Kathleen Kennedy
so if anybody wants to write some Yoda
Maz Kanata fanfic Lupita will probably
be happy to endorse it another good one
JJ Abrams confirmed know he walks and no
Jar Jar in the movie he joked it was one
of Harrison Ford's conditions for doing
the movie so I guess you could also
douse that Jar Jar theory I know
everyone wants to believe in the Darth
Jar Jar theory just because it's so
ridiculous but I do not believe it at
all he also said this is actually a
bigger one - there is no post credit
scene after the movie but that's not
gonna stop me from staying to the end of
the credits you have to remember that
Jon Williams wrote a bunch of new music
for this so there's gonna be an amazing
soundtrack playing over the credits so I
would encourage everyone to stay to the
very end of the movie but in case there
was any confusion this is just the
confirmation there's not gonna be like a
rogue one teaser at the end of the movie
because don't forget rogue one is coming
out next year new Star Wars movie every
single year
Gwendoline Christie actually said that
she didn't know that her Captain phasma
character started out being a male
character before JJ Abrams cast the role
then he decided to make it a female saw
Gwen and Christine was like oh my god
this is perfect I'm so happy I did it
this way and they did confirm that she
would be coming back like she's a very
brief presence in Episode seven she's
gonna have a much bigger role in Episode
eight think about her like Luke
Skywalker appearing in Episode seven in
a small way but much bigger in Episode
eight though and they did say that Rian
Johnson who's directing Episode eight
he's currently in the thick of
production on Episode eight made
continuity a really big deal so even if
you're upset that they threw a lot of
cannon out from the expanding universe
internal continuity of this new trilogy
is a very big deal for them you may have
heard John boyega impersonating Harrison
Ford at some of the other actors he does
impersonations of a lot of the other
actors but he told this funny story
about mace windu so they were asked like
all the actors were asked do you believe
or have you followed any of the fan
theories about your characters so a lot
of people thought that Finn might be the
grandson of mace windu Samuel Jackson's
character so John boyega said he was at
a party earlier this year someone tapped
him on the shoulder and said really loud
yo black Jedi
he turns around and it's samuel
l.jackson himself so Mays Windu himself
who probably hasn't seen the movie yet
thinks that Finn is going to become a
Jedi which i think is kind of funny he
doesn't mean that finn is connected to
mace windu but it's just like a nice
funny real-world meta moment
and you think of Star Wars is such a
huge deal all the new actors were
obviously like super intimidated when
they were going to audition for their
roles John boyega said that just to get
himself pumped up he went back and
watched Mark Hamill and Harrison Ford's
original audition tapes from episode
four but in related news there are a
couple big trailers that are coming they
did confirmed that the Star Trek 3
trailer is gonna be attached to Star
Wars The Force awakens in theaters it'll
probably drop the same week that the
movie drops so new Star Trek trailer
coming really soon and x-men apocalypse
is also probably coming sometime this
week or next week really really soon
I've also seen a little bit of news
about a new Deadpool trailer because
that movie's coming in February so don't
be surprised that there's a new Deadpool
trailer too before the end of the year
here's my big question for you guys
though let me know in the comments what
is like the funniest quote that you've
heard from one of the actors or JJ
Abrams or someone Star Wars related
since they started doing all these
interviews during the Jimmy Kimmel
special whenever you know he was like
jokingly asking Carrie Fisher how the
movie ended she basically told him it
ends of this giant orgy of you know
quote unquote lightsabers you know you
could just imagine what those
lightsabers were but just another reason
why Carrie Fisher is so awesome like
it's so funny to listen to her during
Family Guy episodes being just the
nastiest person ever but if you guys
didn't see either Mark Hamill is going
to be coming back to the flash as the
trickster tomorrow and there's always so
many Star Wars jokes during those
episodes like last year he did the Darth
Vader I am your father a moment so if
you want some really awesome Star Wars
meta stuff happening be sure to watch
the flash tomorrow night I just posted a
trailer video for that Mark Hamill flash
episode so you can click here to watch
that footage so much awesome Mark Hamill
stuff happening watch out for Star Wars
jokes and you can click here for my
latest game of Thrones teaser video
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high-five mostly guys tonight